The answer is because lists are mutable.
That makes them unlikely candidates to put into hash tables.
Here's why.
Let's suppose we did allow lists to be hashable.
Now we're trying to compute the hash function for y,
and let's say we have a very simple hash function--not a very good one--that just says
add up the values of the elements.
Let's also say that the hash of an integer is itself,
so the hash code for this list would be equal to 6, the sum of the elements.
But now the problem is, because these lists are mutable,
I could go in, and I could say, y[0] = 10.
Y would be the list [10, 2, 3].
Now when we check and say, is y in d?
We're going to compute the hash value 10 + 2 + 3 = 15.
That's a different hash value than we had before.
So if we stored y into the dictionary when it had the value 6,
and now we're trying to fetch it when it has the value 15,
you can see how Python is going to be confused.
Now, there's 2 ways you could handle that.
One--the way that Python does take is to disallow putting the list into the hash table
in the first place because it potentially could lead to errors if it was modified.
The other way is Python could allow you to put it in,
but then recognize that it's the programmers fault,
and if you go ahead and modify it, then things are not going to work anymore,
and Python does not take that approach, although some other languages do.